[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MAEVE HIGGINS: Hi.
Thank you so much.
It's funny that like nobody
sat in the front row.
But then you guys just
became the front row,
because you're just one back.
KELLY: It's a very cozy
atmosphere we have, isn't it?
MAEVE HIGGINS: I mean, no.
[LAUGHTER]
A really wide, weird room.
KELLY: I feel like we--
MAEVE HIGGINS: And like lights.
I wouldn't say cozy,
but I would say
thank you so much for
giving up your time
and coming to hear us chatting.
KELLY: We would do well to have
like a little fireplace here,
or--
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yes.
KELLY: --a comically
oversized fish tank.
MAEVE HIGGINS: And maybe drinks.
Yeah?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KELLY: OK, great.
Thanks so much for
joining us today.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Of course.
KELLY: Your book is amazing.
Everybody should read it.
It's fantastic.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Thanks, Kelly.
KELLY: Yeah.
But I want to chat with you
a little bit about your home
life, and where you came from.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Sure.
KELLY: So you've made the rounds
from a comedian to an actress
to a writer.
And you write a lot.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Like if
something doesn't work out, then
I just go.
KELLY: You write a lot in
your book about your home life
in Cobh and how that--
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yes.
KELLY: --influenced you.
So can you tell the
audience a little bit
about where you come from
and what your family is like?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yes.
So I'm from a place in
Ireland called Cobh.
Is there any other
Irish people here today?
Oh, oh my god.
That's cool.
You know Cobh?
Yeah, so it's like
down, down south.
And it's actually a
big immigration town,
which I've been thinking
about recently because it
relates to my work here.
Because I grew up from in
where everybody left from,
like a million people
left from Cobh.
This is a long time ago,
like during the famine,
which is now over.
Obviously we're fine.
I'm actually really full.
But I grew up there.
I'm one of eight children,
which is maybe a little bit more
than the norm I would say.
Like we still have big families
in Ireland, but eight is a lot.
And very happy childhood.
And but I do think that's
where like my obsession
with immigration started,
because we learned about it
in school all the time, even to
like inappropriate levels where
I remember learning
about Maritime tragedies
of like the boats leaving
Cobh and crashing.
And then this one local
historian came into us
and said the people
would be clinging
on to the sides of the
boats, and the other people
would be chopping
their hands off.
And I was like, maybe seven.
[LAUGHTER]
And I don't know that that's
ever been verified anyway.
So always in my mind
that was like oh,
I'm from this place
where people leave from.
And so I write a bit about that.
And I write about
Annie Moore, who
I've been thinking
about these days
so much because she's the first
immigrant through the gates
of Ellis Island.
She left from my hometown
of Cobh in like 18--
it was like the
150th anniversary.
I can't really do the--
it was like 1898 or
something I think.
Is that right?
150.
I don't know.
Anyway, it was
like 150 years ago.
And she was an
unaccompanied minor.
She was 17 years old.
She left with her
two baby brothers.
So three unaccompanied
kids coming across.
No documents, no passport,
no visa, nothing.
And they were welcomed in.
And they were reunited with
their parents, who had come
here years earlier to make--
get an apartment and
start to make a living.
They lived on the
lower east side
for the rest of their lives.
And I just think how different
it was for them compared
to what's happening
to kids today and just
all the various issues of
race and stuff around that.
KELLY: You also lived
in Zimbabwe as a child.
MAEVE HIGGINS: I did
live in Zimbabwe, yeah.
Any Zimbabweans here?
No?
What, are you nodding your head?
Like you are?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Oh,
you're like, as
if there'd be Zimbabweans here.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It's that
it's an unfortunate
comparison between Irish and--
MAEVE HIGGINS: Right.
True, very true.
So much easier for white
immigrants from Europe
to get here than it is for
black immigrants in Zimbabwe.
In fact, I-- yeah, I have a
friend at the moment who is
trying to get the 01 visa, which
is the one I'm on, which is
the alien of
extraordinary ability.
He's like won this big
film festival in Zimbabwe
two years ago.
I was on a hidden
camera show in Ireland.
Like so anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
--he technically is probably
more extraordinary than I am,
but it's proving a
lot more difficult.
And so anyway we
lived in Zimbabwe.
The whole family went to
live there for two years.
My dad was in construction.
He was building a
hotel over there.
And I think that was a
really valuable experience
for me, just from--
if any of you have kids, I don't
have any kids that I know of.
That's like a terrible joke.
You're shaking your head.
You're like, a Google
executive would never say that.
Kelly and I were
talking earlier,
and she normally has to
interview Google executives.
Or not Google executives--
KELLY: Executives generally.
MAEVE HIGGINS:
Executives generally.
KELLY: None of whom
I hope watch this.
MAEVE HIGGINS: No, but
I mean they're great.
But I mean they wouldn't
make terrible jokes.
They're better.
That's better.
They wouldn't be like,
I don't have any kids
that I know of in
like that dumb voice.
KELLY: I think that's lovely.
[LAUGHTER]
MAEVE HIGGINS: But anyway,
what I was going to say
is like if you do have kids, I
really think it's cool to like,
if you can at all, and it's
a hugely privileged thing
to be able to do, to
move country and have
them live somewhere
else when they're small.
So that they can
understand they're
not the center of the
world, them and everyone
who looks like them.
Because in Ireland
everyone is very--
I mean, like look.
[LAUGHTER]
You and me could be sisters.
And so it really was
a great thing for me
to go away and
see like, oh, here
is all these other ways
of living basically.
KELLY: Yeah.
And you write about growing
up in a family where humor
was prized above all else.
So how did that
affect you as a child?
Can you tell the audience
about your family?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah.
I mean, I think--
I don't know if it's
like a big family thing,
if it's an Irish
thing, but certainly
being funny in my family was--
no one cared if you're
athletic or clever or--
being funny was like the thing.
And it wasn't just like
nice funny, you know?
Often there's like
an edge to humor,
and that's definitely
the way my family is.
Where you kind of sit around the
table and you're a little bit
scared, and then it starts.
And it's tough, but it's
like you show your affection
for people by bullying them.
KELLY: I grew up in the
same kind of family,
and I'm curious if
that's the experience
of a lot of other Irish
people in the audience.
MAEVE HIGGINS: I
mean, everyone's
too nervous to put
their hands up,
because they've been
bullied so badly.
KELLY: They're all very shy.
[LAUGHTER]
MAEVE HIGGINS: But what,
how many are in your family?
KELLY: Oh, it's small.
Just two.
But I've got loads of
cousins, like dozens.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yes.
Yeah, I would definitely count
our cousins and even our aunts.
And my aunts still give
me a really hard time.
And yeah, it's
just never-ending.
But I mean, I think that's
good if you end up working
as a comedian the way I did.
But also I would say at
least two of my six sisters
are funnier than I am.
Like Rosie my sister, who still
lives in Cobh where we grew up,
and she's a beautician in Cobh.
And she is like--
first of all, she knows
all the town secrets,
because she does all their
waxing, and you know.
And then and eyebrows
and everything.
And then she's a really
good Impressionist.
And she's just like
so sharp and funny.
But she doesn't have
like a compulsion
to show off about it
like some of us do.
KELLY: When did you
realize that being funny
was your superpower?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Oh,
well I'm not being
self deprecating when I say
I'm not good at anything else.
Like I'm good at writing,
and I'm good at being funny
and do those two
things together.
But I didn't realize the
writing thing until about like
five years ago.
And I still need a
lot of outside what,
like proof of that.
Like now I'm like I
write for the New York
Times, that has to be--
mean something, you know?
KELLY: Yeah, validation.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Validation.
But with being funny I was
always like, I'm funny.
Even though in school and
everything I was quiet,
but I was like the kind of
judgmental outsider one.
And also, I think,
being female, it's
harder to be overtly like I'm
the funniest one in the room.
You're more sly about it.
And so that's kind of
what I always have known.
KELLY: Yeah, well it's
used to great effect.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Thank you.
KELLY: So your writing
has been compared
to if David Sedaris and Tina
Fey had a daughter, which
I think is perfect.
MAEVE HIGGINS: I mean, that's
who's on the cover of the book.
KELLY: I know.
Isn't that beautiful?
MAEVE HIGGINS: But it's also--
KELLY: And so accurate.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Don't you
think it's kind of grotesque?
Because Tina Fey
and David Sedaris
wouldn't have a daughter.
Also, like obviously
David Sedaris is a gay man
and wouldn't have a child
with a straight woman.
And she is not that
much older than me.
KELLY: If you could update
it to fan fiction of who you
would like to have a daughter.
MAEVE HIGGINS: No, I'd
love them to be my parents.
KELLY: Sure.
MAEVE HIGGINS: But I just think
in the natural order of things
it would be highly unusual
to have a 13-year-old mother
and a kind of an
older gay man be my--
be my parent.
KELLY: I guess I see
where you're coming from.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Do
you know what I mean?
KELLY: Yeah, I
know what you mean.
MAEVE HIGGINS: But it's--
Glamor magazine said it.
And then we were
all really happy,
because it's hard
to get good quotes.
So we were like, yeah
put it out there.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY: Yeah.
So who do you look to
for writing inspiration?
MAEVE HIGGINS: For
writing inspiration,
I mean, I definitely, I tend to
read lots of nonfiction books
about war.
So but for funny writing, I do
love David Sedaris actually.
Daddy.
[LAUGHTER]
God, I sometimes think--
KELLY: Well, I'm interested
in hearing about the war books
as well.
Do they influence it?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah.
I don't know that they
influence my writing.
I mean like I certainly--
I write here about
when I went to Iraq.
And I did a workshop in Iraq.
And I definitely
didn't want to be
one of those people
who come from the west
and like land there and spend
a few weeks there and go
on about like oh, the
sound of the mosque
in the early morning,
or the usual crap that
like I feel like white
Western people write
when they go anywhere there.
Or they're like, actually,
the people were friendly.
This kind of-- I hate that.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: So maybe it was
helpful to me that I do read.
There isn't really--
I think my favorite book of the
last years is called like no--
what's it called again?
I told you, I'm so dull today.
It's a book about Afghanistan.
And it's an American who
went to live in Afghanistan.
Anand Gopal is
the writer's name.
It's called like
No Country For--
or like No Good Country For
The Living or something.
Can you Google it?
[LAUGHTER]
Just like everyone
who makes that joke.
No Good Place For The--
No Good Country For The
Living or something like that?
AUDIENCE: Give me a second.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Sorry.
No reception.
Anyway, it's a really cool
book because basically he was--
I think he was like a
neuroscientist, young,
just studying neuroscience.
And then he was downtown
when the World Trade Center
attacks happened.
And he was like stuck
under a car all day.
And that made him think suddenly
about like America's place
in the world, and
about geopolitics
in a way that he hadn't before.
And then he just decided
to move to Afghanistan.
And he lived there and
he learned the language.
And he like got a motorbike
and traveled around
and had access to like even
one member of the Taliban.
And so he just learned so much.
And then he wrote about it in a
way that was and so informative
about what really happened
there, and what the American--
why it's such a mess.
And he also has these
really great human stories.
He traces like three people.
One a Taliban commander,
one is a widow
who ended up in Parliament.
And then he just--
the combination of a news
story deeply researched
and like on the ground,
and also the human.
Both the human cost
and human opportunity,
because both of those things
happen in war obviously.
And so I loved his writing.
And I would say then when
I am writing about Iraq,
or I also went to Iran,
then I try and think.
There's only so much you can
be aware of your own biases
or whatever, but
I am always trying
to think like what if I
didn't grow up in Ireland
and didn't live in America.
Like what would I
really be thinking?
Or what's really happening?
That's helpful.
KELLY: I certainly
see a lot of ties
to that in your journalism, so
your podcast and the articles
that you write for
the New York Times.
That makes total sense.
Where do you find your
reading recommendations
around those issues?
MAEVE HIGGINS: I mean, I am--
I definitely have a lot of
like immigrant journalists
that I follow.
It's not hard to find good,
interesting work written by--
like if I'm going to read about
the Mexican-American border,
I want to read about it from
a Mexican point of view too.
Like very simple.
There's very simple ways to,
I think, inform yourself.
And like it is kind of amazing.
It is kind of amazing
when you realize
all the different points
of view that I'm getting.
You just need to scratch
the surface a bit
and look a bit deeper.
KELLY: I bet a lot
of the audience
hasn't had a chance
to read the book yet.
And I'd love to give them
an insight into what you
did in Iraq, if you could
tell them about that.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Oh, sure.
So I did a comedy workshop.
I'm talking all about war
and I did a comedy workshop.
And I went there in 2016.
And I was in Erbil,
which is up in Kurdistan.
And it's like a very safe
place, but I did tell my parents
that I was going to Kurdistan.
I didn't specify like Iraq.
And then I got two other
comics to come with me.
Well, one is-- he's a TV writer.
Joel Randazzo his name is.
And he used to
write for The Onion.
And then he wrote
for At Midnight,
and a few different places.
And then Mo Amer, who's
a Texan comedian who
tours with Dave Chappelle.
But he's Texan by way of like
his family are Palestinian.
And he's Arabic speaking.
So the three of
us went out there
and we did a workshop with
40 of our Iraqi peers.
I was obviously
like a bit hesitant
about coming from
America to teach.
The history of American
involvement in Iraq
has never been good.
And then also to
like hey, we're going
to-- don't you think
jokes are so important?
And to teach like
comedy or whatever.
But I did my research.
I also, coming from
Ireland as you know,
we were a conflict-ridden
country for a long time.
And I was definitely--
I'm definitely too young to
claim that story as my own,
but certainly when I used to
do gigs in Belfast I remember
the owner of the Empire,
the comedy club up there,
he said that whenever there
was a very bad atrocity,
that that's Sunday night
for the comedy show
there would be like
lines around the block.
And the people
really used comedy
as a way to come together, and
as kind of a form of relief,
and a way to connect
with each other.
And I always found that
really interesting.
Plus like in Northern
Ireland I think
it's fair to say they have
like a slightly darker
hue to their humor.
And so going to Iraq, I
kind of had that on my mind.
I also wanted to talk about
the power of creativity
when you're in--
going through dark stuff,
whether that's just yourself
or it's your family, or it could
be your community or country.
But that's all very lofty.
I was really nervous.
And then I got there.
And of course, it was like doing
a comedy workshop anywhere.
Like there was four
women and 36 men.
And there was like
goofy, loud guys
who were just wanting to
do comedy to meet women.
And then there was like
older, like earnest men who
kind of were--
had always wanted to express
this side of themselves,
but they were working or
looking after a family.
It was just like I could have
named people's equivalents
that I had met in New Zealand,
in Edinburgh, in Dublin.
Do you know what I mean?
KELLY: Absolutely.
MAEVE HIGGINS: It was cool.
And there was cartoonists
there, and people
who made short videos.
And stand-up comedy
is like a younger kind
of a craft in Iraq.
And it was a lot of-- there was
a sketch group there and stuff.
And we just had this workshop.
And it was really good, like
it was really helpful, I think.
It was certainly helpful
for me, and I would hope
it was helpful for them too.
And I'm still in touch with a
few people took the workshop.
And what was extraordinary
was we were just like 40 miles
from Mosul, which was still
under ISIS control at the time.
And they're making
funny videos about ISIS.
And that was kind of the ISIS
is so good at social media,
and at making videos to travel.
And I think that for the
people at the workshop, some of
whose family, they were IDP,
so their family were still
stuck in Mosul.
I think it was useful
for them to have comeback
and to use their
creativity to oppose
this kind of destruction, and
this narrative of destruction.
So that's what they said.
And I think, and I do
believe them actually.
And I also was like god,
I was so stupid coming
out here thinking, oh,
what's the point of this?
Because I was like, well, if I
just happened to grow up here,
I'd be the one in the workshop.
I'd be one of those kind
of like girls being like
is this going to be good?
KELLY: You mentioned the
impulse for self-expression.
So if you were a cave
woman, you would be the one
who's writing on the walls.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Totally.
I'm constantly, as you
can see, trying to say,
like trying to figure out
what I'm thinking and feeling
and how I understand things
and trying to share that.
And it's just a, I
think, it's very human.
Maybe it's like a bit stronger
in some of us than in others.
But I think it's a very
human impulse to try and say
like to just express yourself.
And then to get
heard is amazing.
KELLY: Yeah.
Well, we all reap the benefits
you expressing yourself,
so thank you for that.
MAEVE HIGGINS: You're welcome.
KELLY: So teaching this
comedy workshop opened up
a lot of questions about the
shared space between comedy
and tragedy.
I'm going to read a little
excerpt of a question
that you posed, which is what
if comedy and creativity, these
nebulous things I've
devoted all these years to,
are in fact in the
grand scheme of things
unhelpful or even pointless?
So how did your experience help
to clarify those questions?
And do you still ever
struggle with them?
MAEVE HIGGINS: I think
a lot of times comedy--
like I think that we pat
ourselves on the back too much.
Like I think if you're on the
kind of left side of things,
you watch John Oliver and
you're like yeah, like, get him,
like you said it.
Or Jon Stewart or whatever.
And ultimately I don't
think it's really--
I don't think if your
goal is to change things,
I don't think that's changing.
It's like you get a laugh
and you feel good, but--
and you definitely get that
sense that we're a tribe.
But like that's, I don't
know how helpful that is.
So but for when I went and
spent that time in Iraq,
I do think that I could see the
value of it from kind of a--
just it's an important
part of being human.
And I think often when people
are serious all the time,
even if it's because they're
sad or because something bad is
happening, I think
that's a disservice
to their own humanity.
Because I think in all of us
there is like light and dark,
and there is levity,
and there's depth.
And unless you allow
both of them to come out,
then it's like you're
not being fair.
It's like if you were giddy
and upbeat all the time,
that's not a true representation
of really being human.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: So that's why
I think a lot of narratives
around, of course,
like around war
and of course
around immigration,
forced immigration, like
what's happening to Syrians
are so tragic and so sad.
But within those stories,
which I found in my podcast
when I interviewed Syrian asylum
seekers, like there's jokes.
There is love.
There's humor.
There's all those things that
people who aren't in a war
and people who don't
feel a great sadness,
like they still get to have--
they still get to
have that levity.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: But I think
it gets lost in the telling
sometimes.
KELLY: Yeah.
What made you choose to do
a podcast on immigration?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Well, I think it
was because, like I was saying,
where I came from was--
Ireland is such a country that
pushes people out all the time.
And we end up all
over the world.
And then I became
an immigrant myself,
like moved here five years ago.
And I could definitely see the
contrast between my immigration
experience and so
many other peoples.
And it was definitely a
question of why me, and like
why not them, and why not?
Because America is such
a fortress, really.
So there was that.
There was just that
central question
of what's really going on here.
But also immigration
stories, as you
know if you're an
immigrant yourself if you
know immigrants, there's
always a story there.
Because it literally means
you've left one life behind,
and you've come and
started a new life.
And that is, like from a
storytelling point of view,
there just has to
be something there.
Even in the most boring
immigration story,
there is a story.
There's a beginning and a middle
and then what's happened now.
KELLY: Yeah.
The podcast is no
longer in production,
but the back issues are amazing.
And if you haven't listened
to it, you really should.
It hits all the right notes--
MAEVE HIGGINS: Oh
thank you, Kelly.
KELLY: --to change
hearts and minds.
Absolutely.
MAEVE HIGGINS:
Well, I mean you say
that it changed
hearts and minds,
but like it's interesting
because I really thought--
like so basically the
podcast is quite simple.
It's like me interviewing
different immigrants,
about their own stories.
It's like immigration stories
told by the people who've
lived them.
And I really thought--
we went into production in 2015.
I started the idea
working in 2015,
but the way the timing
worked, the show
only started airing like
right after Trump got elected.
And then I think he was
inaugurated while I was still
taping on the West Coast.
Anyway, and so
obviously immigration
is always a huge
topic here in America,
but it had really heated up.
And I think I did
naively probably think,
oh but if anybody hears
this, like if they hear Zaza,
the Syrian asylum seeker, if
they hear him talking about how
he really needs to quit
smoking because he has
this one-year-old now and his
wife is giving him a hard time,
and yeah, he wants to quit
smoking, but he's afraid
is going to put
weight on because he's
like a comfort eater.
Like he reminded me of my uncle.
And I was like,
when they hear him,
they're not going to
be scared of Syrians.
And they're not going
to even consider
a Muslim ban or whatever.
I don't know that hearing
stories from immigrants
directly does change
facts and minds.
KELLY: I like to
hope that it does.
MAEVE HIGGINS: I hope
that it does too,
but it's hard to get
that qualitative,
like does it actually.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: I don't know.
it's a really-- I'm still
trying to figure out.
KELLY: Yeah.
I think reaching the
correct audience is probably
the hardest part of the battle.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yes, yeah.
KELLY: Yeah.
So there's an innate
tension in the whole book
about the hope you have
for humanity, society,
and the insecurity of the
self that everybody faces.
So can you give us
any words of wisdom
for people in the
audience who might want
to make a difference
in the world
and contribute to change but
need the courage to start?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Well,
I mean, I could
say what I'm doing
at the moment, which
is kind of a small thing.
But it's actually helping me.
So I started this other
podcast this year.
And it's about climate justice
which is something I never--
I knew about, but I wasn't
really paying attention.
Anyway, we did this
issue, we did this episode
about divestment.
Like big, big countries or
corporations or universes
or whatever divesting
their money from, say,
like fossil fuel
funding of fossil fuel
operations to putting
it into something
else, like clean
energy, or something
that's kind of whatever, cleaner
and better for the environment,
and better from a human rights
point of view and stuff.
And so then we did
this whole episode.
And I was kind of
like, OK cool, you
can petition your
government to divest.
The great news is that the
Irish government has recently
divested all of their
money, which is amazing.
But then I was looked
at Chase Bank, which
is just where I
bank for no reason,
except that that's where
I opened up the bank.
And then I was like, oh,
I'm going to move my money.
This is like last week.
I was on the phone with them.
And I owed them four grand.
Like I had like zero on my
current account, and four
grand on my credit card.
So I was like taking
a high moral--
I phoned them, and
I was like I think
I'm going to leave
the bank, because I've
been reading all this stuff.
And you've been funding
this huge tar sands project.
And the lady was
like, you can't leave.
Like you owe us.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was like, no, I
know, but I'm telling you.
Anyway, then because the
day in your book gets
published you get your
check or whatever.
So I got my check
on Tuesday, was it?
Yeah.
And then I was
like, Julia Roberts
kind of that moment where
she goes back into the shop
and she's like, big mistake.
[LAUGHTER]
But still the woman in
Chase was like, fine.
You can leave.
They were just like,
what is your problem?
Anyway, so then like
this other lady,
because I was like I
should record this,
like it's really funny.
And this other lady--
first of all, I called Chase
and I was like, now I have money
and I'm paying off
my credit card.
And you're not getting the
rest of my money or whatever.
And then it's like
a lady who works
in a call center in the
Philippines, you know?
And I wasn't about to
like go off on her.
Do you know what you're doing?
Like climate change
is real problem.
She's in the Philippines.
I think she knows.
We had a really
nice chat actually.
And she was like,
look, I'm going
to do my homework after this.
I was like, OK, sorry to
keep you on the phone.
And then I got put through
to media relations,
because I was
recording or whatever.
And she hung up on me, this lady
in like the Manhattan branch
hung up on me.
So anyway, this is--
I'm sorry, this is a
really long-winded way
of saying I'm personally taking
responsibility for like this
is like a small thing, right?
Where my money goes.
I also, when it
comes to immigration,
I try and really look
at my own status,
which like I said is
I have this 01 visa,
which is a very
privileged one to get.
And I try and help
other people get it.
And I just try and
speak to and understand
other points of view.
It's very basic.
Like I said, when I started
the podcast I was like,
my responsibility
as a storyteller
is to change the attitude
towards immigration
in this country.
And it's like, no.
I can't do that.
Like what I can do
personally, really do,
is like these small things.
I can-- another thing which is
more, again, climate justice
related is like check
where my food comes from.
And not just order
Seamless all the time,
which is like a lot of
packaging and a lot of very--
so I'm doing very small things.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: That's
like my latest approach.
KELLY: Yes.
I'm hearing start small,
and speak to your talents.
Because you've leveraged your
talents in incredible ways
to effect change.
I want to leave space
for audience questions.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Sure.
KELLY: So please don't be shy
if you want to ask something.
We've got microphones.
MAEVE HIGGINS: You
could ask me for a loan.
Now is a good time.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY: But also this book was
completed about a year ago,
is that right?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah.
I basically finished
it last September.
And then it's quite a long
process with publishing.
It takes a while.
KELLY: What's changed
in your life since then?
MAEVE HIGGINS: I've got a dog.
I got a dog.
I got made a columnist at the
Times and at the Guardian.
And also at the Progressive,
another magazine.
So suddenly now I have a
lot of writing work to do,
which is fine.
And I think that's kind of it.
KELLY: Yeah, that's big.
You have a really cute
passage about-- so many
cute passages about
dogs in this book.
I love it.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Well you see,
because I used to always walk
dogs from Sean Casey.
It's like a rescue place.
And you can walk dogs from
there, like you don't have to--
I mean really you just go in
and give your email address.
I think they kind of want
you just to take them.
[LAUGHTER]
And then you can take the
dog to the park or whatever.
And I used to always do that.
And I was like, I
got to get a dog.
Well, money and like looking
at the time and everything.
But then I just kind of--
I don't know if you
have a dog, but what
happens is you act
like you're just
going to foster it for a while.
Anyway, I ended up getting this
dog full time now for almost.
And it's great.
Like actually when I
got her I was like,
I guess she's like
half border collie,
so I was like she's going to
be really busy and energetic.
And she's going to
make me start running.
I used to run.
I don't run anymore.
And then I was like,
it's going to be so good
for me and my mental health.
And I'm going to lose
weight and everything.
She's also a half--
anyway, she's like the laziest.
Not lazy, but like she's
a puppy and she's just
like let's snooze.
So she, yeah.
So that's what's happened to me.
KELLY: She's quite
large for a puppy.
MAEVE HIGGINS: She's
a big puppy, yes.
She's 60 pounds now, because
she just sleeps all the time.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY: That'll do it.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah.
Yeah.
KELLY: And so we
covered your trip
to Iraq and mentoring
Iraqi comics.
And all the issues
that come up for you.
MAEVE HIGGINS: And my dog.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Oh, we
hit all the big ones.
KELLY: Around the
Berlin utility of comedy
and its relationship
to tragedy there
was this really
interesting juxtaposition
in the book about your hope
for all of these comics
and how they can affect
change, and being
very positive and
optimistic about the role
of comedy and politics in Iraq.
But I saw a lot of
insecurity bubbling up
around the podcast
and its ability
to affect change
in the same way.
Imposter syndrome
is something that we
talk about a lot at Google.
It's a big discussion point.
So do you have any
words of wisdom
about kind of closing that
gap between how you perceive
other people and how you
can bring your own self
perception to the same place?
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah.
I mean, this newest
podcast that I'm working on
is with Mary Robinson, who's
the former president of Ireland.
She's their first
female president.
And she's 73 years old now.
And so you can imagine what it
was like for her coming off.
She was a human rights
lawyer first in like,
I guess the '70s
in Ireland, which
was a tough time for women.
And she was like a
human rights lawyer.
So anyway I asked
her about that,
because I think it's like a real
phenomenon with younger women.
Maybe men feel it too,
imposter syndrome.
I hear it most from women,
but maybe men feel it too.
And I asked her about it.
And she was like,
I never had it.
[LAUGHTER]
She was so unhelpful.
Like I really thought that she'd
have some kind of like wise,
and she was just
like I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
And someone else that
I talked to about this,
she's a black woman.
And she was like, that
I don't have time for--
she's like, everyone
does doubt me.
Everyone in her, I guess
she means not black people,
does doubt her and she does have
to prove herself all the time.
So if she also doubts herself--
so that made me think this
is just one black woman.
I don't know if that's--
but that made me
think like I wonder
if it's a bit of making a
problem where there isn't one.
But I feel it.
It's a real-- and I
know like feelings
aren't facts, but whatever.
I do still feel it a bit myself.
KELLY: Yeah.
MAEVE HIGGINS: And I feel like
what do I think I'm doing here,
or if I'm doing like
a high-status thing
or whatever, I'm like, me?
I think it's helpful to
remind yourself of past.
Like using logic helps me.
Like I can say to myself,
but you did this other thing
like two weeks ago, and
that was on the same level
and you did fine.
So like using logic to say
like, I wasn't cut out then.
Nobody kicked me out then.
So I can do this again.
And then I use that for a lot
of things to trick my brain.
Like I often think,
oh, I'm not going
to be able to write this piece.
Like it's too hard, or it's
too long, or it's whatever.
I don't have time.
But then I think,
but you thought that
before but you did it.
So just using evidence
from your past.
KELLY: That's amazing.
I mean, we're a very
databased company.
It should resonate for us.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah?
KELLY: Yeah.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us at Google today.
Maeve in America: Essays by
a Girl From Somewhere Else
is now available.
Pick it up on Google Play.
We have copies in the back.
Hopefully, Maeve
will be around--
MAEVE HIGGINS: Thank you, Kelly.
KELLY: --to sign
some copies as well.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Sure.
KELLY: Yeah.
But thank you so
much for joining us.
It was a pleasure.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Thank you, Kelly.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, you ask such
good questions too.
KELLY: Thank you.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah, like
you really read the book.
I was doing radio
interviews this week.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't know.
I was doing radio this week.
Radio interviews.
And then some people were
like, oh Maeve, so great
to talk to you.
Anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY: I'm just in it
for the compliments.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Does
anybody have any questions?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Did you also change
the spelling of your name
for America?
MAEVE HIGGINS: No, but
there are other spellings,
more complicated ways
to spell my name.
But luckily this was the
one my parents gave me.
I know another Maeve,
she's like, M-A-E-D-H-B-H.
[LAUGHTER]
And people are just like
ha, [SPEAKING NONSENSE]..
[LAUGHTER]
So I was good.
This is like kind
of the phonetic.
Like people definitely
call me Ma-eve.
But I answer it.
That's fine.
Mauve is my worst, because
I don't like that color.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm just like what?
But I do answer to Mauve.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you going--
are you done now with stand-up
and, let's say, improv?
Are you going to
focus on writing?
Could you see yourself
going back to that?
MAEVE HIGGINS: I mean, I
still do bits of stand-up.
Like definitely writing
is 80% or 90% probably now
of my time and stuff.
But I do a show every Monday
in Brooklyn with my friends.
Aparna Nancherla
and Jo Firestone,
two very good comics.
And we do a show
there every Monday.
That kind of keeps my hand in.
And I see all the
youngsters coming up.
But I don't-- but yeah, it's
mainly writing now, yeah.
Yeah.
You have a lovely accent.
[MURMURED LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Cork as well.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Cork as well.
Where are you from?
AUDIENCE: Dublin.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Dublin?
AUDIENCE: Donegal.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Donegal.
We have a good spread
of Irish people here.
KELLY: Beautiful.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Yeah.
KELLY: All right, thank
you so much everybody.
MAEVE HIGGINS: Thanks everyone.
[APPLAUSE]